[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette zone de protection elle a été
créée par la loi du grand paris en 2010
c'est d'ailleurs la même loi du grand
paris qui confirmait le projet de paris
saclay en temps coopération
internationale elle met un coup d'arrêt
à
grignotage des terres agricoles qui
étaient observés sur 7 sur ce plateau de
saclay dans les décennies précédentes et
donc à participe à réduire
l'artificialisation des terres agricoles
et naturels cette dette peinait
s'inscrit dans notre stratégie
développement durable et responsabilité
sociétale pour le territoire paris
saclay comme élément essentiel est un
véritable atout pour notre territoire
sur ce territoire effectivement on sent
que tu as he is plus de 4000 hectares
espaces agricoles naturelles et
forestier mais c'est aussi avant tout un
territoire qui vit un territoire
dynamique c'est aussi un lieu
d'innovation puisqu'on est en lien avec
les chercheurs de l'université dans le
cadre d'un certain nombre de programmes
de recherche la zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière c'est
une charte pour cadrer la gouvernance
avec un règlement qui est associé c'est
surtout un programme d'action justement
pour participer à animer cette zone un
programme d'action partenariale puisque
aujourd'hui ce sont 23 pilotes qui
pilotent 28 actions depuis 2010 est et
jusqu'à 2023 nous faisons aussi un
travail d'évaluation très rigoureux
chaque année pour voir les bénéfices de
cette zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière et ce travail
permettra d'alimenter
l'élaboration du prochain programme
d'action dès l'année prochaine
alors si on en vient aux actions
proprement dit qu'on a valorisé dans ce
livret d'étape il y a trois axes le
premier axe consiste à assurer la
pérennité de l'activité agricole donc
les actions que l'on retrouve dans cet
axe définissent les conditions du
maintien d'une agriculture viable
productif dynamique concernant l'axé b
il s'agit d'assurer la pérennité des
espaces naturels agricoles et
forestières donc on est sur des actions
qui permettent de mettre en place une
gestion optimisée de ces espaces de
concilier agriculture et environnement
et puis enfin donc là que c'est donc les
actions de cet axe permettent d'assurer
les liens entre ces zones agricoles
naturelles et forestières et les
quartiers urbains
c'est assez exceptionnel de se dire que
demain à 500 mètres de la gare de la
future ligne 18 à palaiseau par exemple
on sera à 500 m de la z pena pour partir
en balade à pied ou à vélo
[Musique]